here corn or maize plays the leading
role
nowhere else is so much of it used in
cookery as in Mexico in the south
quesadillas cheese filled corn tortillas
are very popular this snack bar in tapa
Tula has been serving them for 15 years
the dough is made of cornmeal water salt
and a bit of shortening
just about every Mexican has a tortilla
press in the kitchen though usually
slightly smaller in size first the
tortillas are precooked the term
quesadilla is a combination of the word
tortilla and case' which means cheese
but many other ingredients can be added
to the filling a look at the menu tells
you what they are we have the most beef
tribe sausage bacon rind mushrooms pork
or chicken before they're eaten the kiss
ideas are opened up again so the spicy
extras can be added
the quesadillas here are extra large
customers pay less than the equivalent
of two euros for each but that's not the
only reason they're so popular the
tortilla is made of corn and the sauce
with chiles and lemons gives you a taste
that's typical of here typical of Mexico
and how often can you eat a kiss Adelia
like this almost every evening but not
every evening
well then till tomorrow evening and the
next quesadilla
you